thè các khoản chi cho khám vệnh chữ bệnh tại các cư sợi tế trong nước dạm chữ tối đá 20%
chỉ phí giáo dục đầu tạo tại các cư sợ trong nước nược dạm chữ không qua 20%
các khoản này phải có hoa đưa trứng tư trong vỏ khoản chi cho y tế và có thêm bản kê chỉ việc khám chữ bệnh thư quy định của bủy tế
trước nó 1 tài chính tinh tòan về lục thế có 1 về vụ thuộc và phát sinh các khoản chi phí tế sáo dục đầu tạo
có thể được dạm chữ lên tới 30% bệnh 30% nộn mỗi đam
tức 2 bị tạm về sáo viên 3 trường đầu 1 tháng
khoản này 1 quý lắm về nắm chữ đồng cho bản thân về lục tối
về cuộc thuộc sáo về 2 trường đầu 1 tháng và khoản chi cho phí y tế sáo dục tối đá 40%
ý vệnh người lục tối có thuộc dập chết 2 bị tạm về sáo viên 3 trường đầu 1 tháng 4 vài đục tối
với mức tối sất mắt đầu tự năng phần trang
khang số liệu điều tra mức sống cựr dân chữ tiêu bình quân cho y tế
tháng 2 gử dạm chữ trạm 1 tư của 1 người là 3 phải nắm chữ đồng chữ 1 năm
lội chú 4 về 2 trường
giáo dục đồng tạo là chỉ về sáo chữ đồng
Bộ tài chức tiết 2 mỗi nâm người được tối và một về cuộc thuộc chi khoản 1 bốt trường đầu
cho y tế sáo dục
theo bộ tài chữ tầm bớt giảm chữ ra cạnh tiến thao năm
của một về độ tối có thể gấp kần 2 về một y lắm lần thuy ra bình quân đầu người
xám hai gử dụng trạm mi lắm
làm một chấp hay bilam vậy nắm chữ đồng
quy định này giúp giảm nghĩ buồn tối cho tất cả người độ tối có trì vị tế sáo dục